що тріумф російську систему ПВО яка
експортна ціна якої мільярд доларів
уразила українська ракета Нептун і це
демонстрація того що ми можемо знаєте і
дуже прикро що те українське
підприємство яке виробляє нептуни
сьогодні опинилося на грані банкрутства
Чому Тому що частина влади у вигляді
однієї структури
конфліктує з іншою частиною Владі і
заручниками цього стало підприємство
нашої військово-промислового комплексу
Це ж треба окремо Постанову верховної
ради приймати щоби розблокувати отакий
елементарне питання Що роблять оці
міністри начальники і разом з їхні
радники і так далі коли вони доводять
ситуацію до такої